eine redeschlacht heute hier in berlin
der kanzler aufgetreten der
oppositionsführer der finanzminister und
später noch der wirtschaftsminister beim
tag der industrie und da geht es
natürlich vor allen dingen um alle
fragen rund um unsere energie das hat
der kanzler dazu zu sagen haben wir
direkt mal rein
russlands unerbittlicher angriffskrieg
gegen die ukraine ist ein fundamentaler
schlag gegen die europäische
friedensordnung und ein eklatanter bruch
des internationalen völkerrechts das
bedeutet einen epochalen umbruch in
europa und der welt eine zeitenwende für
uns alle
deshalb liefern wir der ukraine waffen
viele davon übrigens auch dank der engen
zusammenarbeit mit deutschen
rüstungsfirmen und deshalb arbeiten wir
gegen russland mit beispiellos harten
sanktionen sanktion die wirken das ende
der eeg-umlage war eine der ersten
maßnahmen der von mir geführten
bundesregierung überhaupt zum ersten
juli wird sie abgeschafft
so hohe strompreise das waren 25
milliarden nur mal so oder so
noch ist es nicht in kraft sie sollten
sich also noch ein bisschen freuen
er ein lachender kanzler der heute beim
tag der industrie wir haben ein bisschen
gefragt was sind jetzt sagen die
antworten auf unsere drängenden fragen
und haben uns über die gute stimmung so
ein ganz bisschen gewundert hier wartet
live im studio zugeschaltet jetzt frank
umbach der sich beruflich an der uni
bonn ja genau mit diesen fragen von
energiesicherheit beschäftigt haben sie
heute beim kanzler irgendwelche
antworten auf die drängenden fragen nach
energiesicherheit herauslesen können
ja zumindest keine neuen antworten
gegeben und er ist natürlich einigen
fragen und diskussionen natürlich
ausgewichen also wir haben ja seit
wochen eine diskussion ob nicht nur die
kohle kraftwerke wieder ans laufen
kommen sondern eben auch die
kernkraftwerke und da haben wir eine
ganze reihe von sicherheits experten die
ja gesagt haben in den letzten wochen
das ist eigentlich kein
sicherheitsgründe geben gibt warum sie
nicht länger laufen könnten wir könnten
noch die brennstäbe länger laufen lassen
und dann muss ich noch mal daran
erinnert an 2011 nach fukushima als wir
die kernkraftwerke
beschlossen haben auszusteigen
damals hat die eu einen test gemacht bei
allen kernkraftwerken innerhalb der eu
da ist rausgekommen dass die deutschen
kernkraftwerke die sichersten
kernkraftwerke in europa sind das heißt
alle kernkraftwerke an den deutschen
grenzen in belgien frankreich der
tschechischen republik sind deutlich
unsicherer als die deutschen und
deswegen kommen auch viele
sicherheitsexperten zu dem ergebnis dass
eine laufzeitverlängerung
temporär
über mehrere jahre kein wirklich keine
wirklichen sicherheitsprobleme
hervorrufen würden es mangelt allerdings
glaube ich an dem politischen willen
weil es insbesondere für die grüne
partei nach der kröte die man geschluckt
hat man den kohlekraftwerken
offensichtlich unmöglich erscheint dass
auch die kernkraftwerke länger laufen
sollten was aber notwendig wäre mit
blick auf die auffüllung der gasspeicher
das wort kernkraft hat der kanzler heute
noch nicht mal einen das genau männer
und die grünen sie haben es angesprochen
die redner von kohle und wir alle
stellen uns hier die frage was muss
endlich passieren damit wir im winter
nicht frieren müssen die frage auch an
sie
ja ich glaube die drosselung der
gaslieferungen es war ja zunächst 40
prozent letzte woche zwei tage später
waren es schon 60 prozent
muss man wirklich ernst nehmen
normalerweise hab auch ich die letzten
wochen immer argumentiert dass russland
kein ökonomisches interesse hat
vollständig auf gaslieferungen nach
europa zu verzichten weil dieses gas
anders als das erdöl nicht anderweitig
auf die weltmärkte gebracht werden kann
das heißt russland würde dann auf seinem
gas sitzen bleiben ohne etwas zu
verdienen aber wir haben bereits gesehen
putin lässt sich nicht unbedingt von
ökonomischen interessen und
nationalitäten leiten und deswegen kann
man eben nicht völlig ausschließen dass
er tatsächlich seinerseits so ein
gasexport in richtung
europa auch gegenüber deutschland
entsprechend greift und dementsprechend
sind die risiken hoch und es wäre besser
gewesen wir hätten bereits die
gaskraftwerke mehr oder weniger vom netz
genommen und wären bereits umgerüstet
hätten sozusagen diesen sprung gemacht
dass die kohlekraftwerke bereich laufen
weil er damit eine höhere sicherheit
bekommen hätten die gasspeicher zu
füllen danke an frank umbau der an der
uni bonn der experte für energie und
energiesicherheit dort ist herzlich dank
für das gespräch